مدينه هيروشيما اليابانيه الرئيس
الاوكراني بمدينه
تصريحكي امام الصحفيين اثناء حضوره قمه
مجموعه السابع لم يكن يقصد به الاساءه الى
رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الحليف الاول له
بالطبع لكنه اكد ان صوره
يذكره تذكره وتجمعات السكنيه المماثله
ايضا المنهاره مبانيها تصريح لم يمر مرور
الكرام حيث التقطته سريعا المتحدثه الرسمي
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه التي
ردت على الرئيس الاوكراني بقولها لا تنسى
ان البيت الابيض رتب الامرين في اشاره
منها الى ان امريكا وراء تذكيه الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني الذي تجلى باعنف صوره في
باخد وايضا مدينتيه هيروشيما
اللتين قصفتها بنووي الامريكي في نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه في العام
1945 نتابع
القول بصراحه ان صوره هيروشيما المدمره
تذكرني بباخمت وغيرها من المدن المماثله
لا يوجد شيء على الاطلاق تم تدمير جميع
المباني لا يمكن حتى ادراك اماكن الشوارع
والمباني هذا دمار كامل مطلق لا يوجد شيء
ولا يوجد بشر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات